il était important pour nous de créer
une cohérence au niveau de toutes les
villes avec lesquelles l'eau possédant
l'inspiration jumelage nous avons
effectivement procédé à une première
opération de jumelage avec la ville de
houilles que la ville de naissance de la
famille de victor schoelcher la ville de
fessenheim pardon et maintenant il
s'agit de faire en sorte que nous
puissions avec la ville de huê perpétue
justement cette tradition à travers une
ville justement au victor schoelcher à
vivre une bonne partie de sa vie et où
l'un est mort également
donc sur cette base là il était
important pour nous de créer les
conditions justement de des changes qui
puisse nous permettre de nous rappeler
ce que fut ce grand homme sont
abolitionnistes victor schoelcher alors
20 ans de jumelage se doit faire un
bilan ça donne quoi
les deux municipalités bien le bilan
positif pourquoi parce que on ne
regrette jamais d'échangés
on n'aurait jamais non plus le principe
d'amitié entre les peuples ne regrette
jamais de faire en sorte que nous
puissions reconstruire l'avenir de nos
enfants
sur la base de valeurs et ce qui nous
rassemble autour de victor schoelcher
dans la ville de shenzhen
la ville de hoi c'est justement ses
valeurs ses valeurs de tolérance et
valeurs d'humanité valeurs d'humanisme
ci de ça qu'il s'agit